taxes aren't just a way to raise money
for the state they're an instrument of
social control if you don't like
something you tax it into Extinction so
with that in mind you should know that
the state of New York currently imposes
a 75 percent tax on cigars
because they're so dangerous number of
Americans killed each year by cigars
not many
but a new tax would increase would be
increased under a law it looks like it's
going to pass to 95 percent on cigars in
the state of New York meanwhile the tax
on cannabis in New York is 13 percent
why is that well lujo Amino is a
criminal defense attorney on Staten
Island and
a Cigar Aficionado and so we're inviting
him tonight to explain the disparity so
your your defense lawyer you're very
familiar with disparities powder and
cracked cocaine and the rest why the
disparity in taxes 95 for cigars which
do not hurt you
and 13 on weed which increases your
chance of getting schizophrenia what is
this
Tucker thanks for having me as you know
I am a cigar smoker and I guess that's
why you had me on tonight you know it
seems like the government will not be
happy unless they have us all eating cow
drinking carrot juice and smoking weed
all right they're not happy with a nice
good cigar I mean to tax something at 95
percent is absurd they want to tax it
into Extinction like you said but why
you know who gets hurt here Tucker the
mom and pop cigar cigar shop down in the
corner that's who gets hurt here not the
rich people because you know where
they're buying the cigars on the illegal
Market the Cubans on the illegal Market
they get their full boxes and they're
not taxed but the the average Joe that
wants us to enjoy a nice cigar on his
porch at night with a nice glass of red
wine or a nice Martini he is the one
that's getting hurt
of course as always but I don't even
understand the justification for it so
if you moderately smoke cigars and don't
inhale them and you're not not burning
10 a day or something if you have an
occasional cigar the health risk is
negligible that's just true people get
hysterical when you say that but it's
true so there's clearly no Public Health
crisis posed by Cigar smoking of all
things what is this
so
Tucker I don't know I can't explain it
all I can explain to you is that
everything we seem to enjoy whether it's
a glass of red wine a drink a nice cigar
they're going to tax you know what's
coming next Tucker I brought a prop you
know what's coming next because the
Elites at Davos have already warned us
for this
red meat our big fat steaks that's what
they're going to be texting next that's
what they're going to be taxing next red
meat it's coming Tucker because we enjoy
that well of course and taking someone's
pleasure away is the ultimate sign of
power right uh Lou it's great to see you
tonight thank you for that keep smoking
them thanks for having us talker thank
you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight